thanks to Skillshare for keeping legal
eagle in the air learn to think like a
lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description hey
legal eagles it's time to think like a
lawyer or today it's time to laugh like
a lawyer because we're going to have a
change of pace and instead of destroying
your favorite childhood movie or
explaining why your favorite legal drama
is completely full of holes Stella and I
are going to review some lawyer jokes
they're gonna make fun of me so what
I've done is I've asked a friend to
compile some lawyer jokes for me I
haven't seen these ahead of time but let
me know if you guys like this change of
format and I've done enough stuff about
PewDiePie to know that meme review is a
thing so let me know if you want me to
respond to legal or law school memes
I would love to make this a continuing
thing because who are we if we can't
laugh at ourselves let's see if this is
clean okay but without further ado let's
dig in to the first lawyer jokes an
attorney was working late one night in
his office when suddenly Satan appeared
before him the devil made him an offer I
will make it so you win every case that
you trying for the rest of your life
your clients will worship you your
colleagues will be in awe and you will
make an enormous amount of money but in
return you must give me your soul your
wife's soul the souls of your children
your parents grandparents and those of
all of your friends the lawyer thought
about it for a moment and then asked but
what's the catch okay you know we might
not have souls but we care about the
souls of the loved ones that are in our
lives also by the way it wouldn't be
unusual for Satan to operate in front of
us like that that happens every day
what's the difference between a lawyer
and a jellyfish one is a spineless
poisonous blob the other is a form of
sea life god I would say that most of
the lawyers that I know are actually
very courageous and are willing to work
very very hard for their clients why
would a lawyer be spineless I mean the
poisonous okay sure
a fifty year old lawyer who has been
practicing since he was 25 passed away
and arrived at the pearly gates for
judgment the lawyer said to st. Peter
there must be some mistake I'm only
fifty years old and that's far too young
to die st. Peter frowned and consulted
his book that's funny when we added up
all your billing records you should be
at least eighty-three by now I like that
one this one it's close to home because
there are some lawyers out there who are
unethical and they will build their
client for more work than they have
actually done and this is this is
reasonably ethical where you're on a
plane and because of the shift in time
zones you're actually able to build more
than 24 hours in the entire day if you
were literally working every single hour
of the day so you you know you spent you
were up all night you did an all-nighter
and then you flew backwards from the
East Coast the West Coast it is
conceivably possible and there are some
rock star associates who have been known
to do that
but yeah fair point God let's see if
this is clean
what is the Bar Association code of
ethics prevent sex between lawyers and
their clients to prevent clients from
being billed twice essentially the same
service you know hopefully you have a
better experience than will say getting
screwed by your attorney actually you
know California just changed their
ethics rules it used to be that in
California you could engage in a
romantic romantic relationship with your
client and now at least during the
pendency of your relationship is
unethical in California to have that
relationship with your clients so
realistically speaking you can get in
big trouble in California now that's a
that's a big change
at a convention of biological scientists
one researcher remarks to another did
you know that in our lab we have
switched from mice to lawyers for our
experiments really the other replied why
did you switch well for three reasons
first we found that lawyers are far more
plentiful second the lab assistants
don't get so attached to them and
thirdly there are some things even a rat
won't do but frankly you know if you
hire a lawyer and you need them to help
you on your case you're gonna want them
to be flexible and to be a zealous
advocate and to really get in the
trenches with the rest of the rats oh my
god lawyers are far more expensive than
rats though why did New Jersey get all
the toxic waste in California get all
the lawyers New Jersey got first pick
alright fair enough
the California legal market is huge
that's where I have practiced for most
of my career frankly yeah I prefer
California to New Jersey so suck at New
Jersey to physicians boarded a flight
out of Seattle one sat in the window
seat the other sat in the middle seat
just before takeoff an attorney got on
and took the aisle seat next to the two
physicians the attorney kicked off his
shoes wriggled his toes and was settling
in when the physician in the window seat
said I think I'll get up and get a coke
no problem said the attorney I'll get it
for you when he was done one of the
physicians picked up the attorneys shoe
and spat in it when he returned with a
coke the physician said that looks good
I think I'll have one too again the
attorney obligingly went to fetch it and
while he was gone the other physician
picked up the other shoe and spat in it
the attorney returned and they all sat
back and enjoyed the flight as the plane
was landing the attorney slipped his
feet into his shoes and knew immediately
what had happened how long must this go
on he asked this fighting between our
professions this hatred this animosity
the spitting in shoes pissing and cokes
so I have a lot of doctor friends I
don't think there's much animosity
between lawyers and and and and doctors
really it's just between me and and dr.
Mike because we've never done a
collaboration you know what you've done
dr. Mike dude you're hilarious and if
you ever want to make a youtube video
I'm so down
a lawyer was filling out a job
application when he came to the question
have you ever been arrested he answered
no next question intended for applicants
who had answered yes was why the lawyer
answered it never got caught so the
thing is it's really the rare exception
that it's like a Bernie Madoff or you
know some other corporate raider who has
done some illegal act that and the
doctors they're the real criminals a
[Music]
secretary a paralegal and a partner in a
city law firm are walking through a park
on their way to lunch when they find an
antique oil lamp they rub it and a genie
appears out of a puff of smoke the genie
says I only grant three wishes so I'll
give each of you just one me first me
first says the secretary I want to be in
the Bahamas driving a speedboat without
a care in the world
poof she's gone me next me next says the
paralegal I want to be in Hawaii
relaxing on the beach with my personal
masseuse and an endless supply of pina
coladas and a love of my life
poof he's gone you're next the genie
says to the partner the partner says I
want those two back in the office after
lunch oh there's definitely some truth
to that I have had some great luck in my
career to have some fantastic legal
secretaries and paralegals in my office
and they have saved my bacon on more
than one occasion man you're not getting
away that easily all right let's see
this one is in the first person I was in
juvenile court prosecuting a teen
suspected of burglary when the judge
asked everyone to stand in state his or
her name and role for the court reporter
Leah Roush deputy prosecutor I said
Linda Jones probation officer Sam Clark
public defender John said the teen who
was on trial I'm the one who stole the
truck okay yeah that one hits close to
home
if only I could control what my client
said at all times because they have a
habit of saying the worst possible thing
at the worst possible time it's a mark
of a good lawyer when you can control a
very bad witness
when my 88 year old mother was called
for jury duty she had to submit to
questioning by the opposing lawyers
that's called why dear have you ever
dealt with an attorney ask the
plaintiff's lawyer yes I had an attorney
write my living trust she responded how
did that turn out I don't know she said
ask me when I'm dead ah some good old
fashioned in the states and trust humor
that's that's always great all right
last one here we go what's the
difference between a good lawyer and a
bad lawyer a bad lawyer might let a case
drag on for several years a good lawyer
knows how to make it last even longer to
mean to mean oh were those good were
those good lawyer jokes all right those
jokes were terrible and you were a bad
person if you laughed at them completely
unfunny and not a kernel of truth in the
whole lot of them but if you want to
learn how to write hit online content
that makes people laugh and share not
like those jokes then you should
definitely check out Matt Bella sighs
Skillshare class called going viral
right film and make content people share
matt teaches you how to write comedy
gold and create viral content that
people love to share the writers of
those jokes really should have taken his
class because all of those jokes were
not funny
Matt's lessons are packed with tips
about originality developing your comedy
voice tweeting better tweets creating
better videos and writing headlines that
will grab you like unfunny people write
bad jokes about lawyers Skillshare is an
online learning community that has over
30,000 classes on everything like
lifestyle design and technology the
first 500 legal eagles will get two free
months of Skillshare when you click on
the link below plus it really helps out
this channel the free premium membership
gives you unlimited access to must know
topic so you can improve your skills and
learn new things all free for two months
improve yourself now so you can write
good jokes which won't involve lawyers
because lawyers are above comedy so
click on a link below get two free
months of skill share and start learning
to think like a lawyer today alright so
as always leave your objections in the
comments and send me your memes and
lawyer jokes I would love to do this
again and check out my other real law
reactions over here where I just reacted
to Marvel's daredevil including the
trial of Frank Castle so click on this
playlist and I'll see you in court